a win and they will host the white sox
in the playoffs and they're going to try
and get a win for jayco to rizzy
this one is lighting to center field and
that's a base hit
so tony kim
a couple of hits last night and he leads
off the ball game with the base hit
tonight so here's starling marte
let's hit hard baits in left center
field
kemp hits the bag at second the ball is
knocked down by alvarez but not picked
up and digging around second or around
third and heading home is kemp and
around second into third is marte with a
triple
so here's pinder pinder drives on the
other way and that's gonna get down and
it's gonna bang off the base of the wall
pinder is gonna head into second with an
rbi double and it's two to nothing the
a's lead
paul blackburn making his ninth and
final start of the season
there were 36 swings and only five
swings and misses as altuve has a base
hit to start this one jose altuve snaps
it over eight with a leadoff single here
in the bottom half of the
[Applause]
first just missed the bottom of the zone
sean murphy popped out
thinking that was a strike but instead
it's ball four to bregman
well here's jordan alvarez he's been
sitting on 32 home runs 101 rbis ever
since last wednesday
there's a crusher to right field jordon
alvarez gives the astros the lead
went down and got an o2 pitch a
three-run home run that's home run
number 33
rbi total up to 104.
they stayed with the off speed but
jordan
goes down and gets this one
curveball down and in out of the zone
jordan gets the head out on it barrels
it up and shoots it into the right field
seats
at 108.6 miles an hour
jason castro bat big night last night
for jason
castro lifts it down the left field line
slicing over toward the corner going
back as brown looking up and attending
the landry's crawford boxes
[Applause]
jason castro goes deep for a second
straight day
to two astros
two seamer up and away there you go get
the barrel to it and elevate
either get it off that wall or up and
over it like he just did
myers ropes one into right field he's
the best plumber in this series have
been better
got a couple of rbi hits last night
that's a fair ball down the left field
line bounds back into shallow left field
jake myers is going to hold up
that'll just be a single for jose altuve
brantley in his bid for an american
league batting crown now down four
points to his teammate julie guriel
brantley goes the other way looper seth
brown a long run he'll play it on a hop
myers heads to third and he will stay
there
[Applause]
on the ground towards the hole cosma
diving stop able to get brantley on a
fielder's choice run crosses the plate
very nice defensive play to keep the
ball on the infield and get it out but
it's now five to two on the bregman
ground now so yuli's biggest competition
right now for a batting title is the guy
hitting three spots ahead of him in the
lineup michael brandley brantley with a
single on the left in the second inning
is hitting 313 and yuli's currently at 3
16.
that ball hit well left field all the
way back goes brown looks up and it's
off the top of the wall yielding
into second base he's gonna have a
double
that's a bomb
i think dusty's gotta jump out of that
dugout i think it hit that railing above
the bank of america yellow line out
there and shot back they tried to beat
him in again and it stayed elevated out
over the plate but that's a home run
watch where this hits
oh yeah that's above the yellow line
we've got it thank you my gosh i was
gonna run onto the field of dusty didn't
there it is
number 15.
home run yuli guriel it's now a 6-2 game
[Applause]
hinder on 3-2 takes it up and in and
he's going to walk
and that one
pops away from castro pinder's gonna try
for second the throw may have hit pinner
but it rolls into center field and
pinder's gonna end up at third point
five three this year
high towering drive that is way up there
that's off the raptors it hits the
rafter and jordan alvarez is going to
catch it in the air
that hit the raptor up there redirected
and jordan alvarez caught it in the air
in fair territory
bob melvin is going to try and argue
that it was foul but that should be in
play for the final out of the inning
and if this drops they score a run yeah
jayco derisi has thrown 63 pitches and
this one is sent up the middle on the
64th pitch sean murphy
has the lead off single here in the
fifth
this one is driven to left toward the
corner alvarez going back turns around
and bangs off the wall grabbed quickly
by alvarez murphy digging around third
he's gonna come in to score now kemp
headed for second and he is tagged out
and that one rolled into left field a
base hit
so 3-1 sliders outside and it's another
wall
two outs bases loaded a 3-2 count to
seth brown
ground ball right side altuve has it
and makes the play to keep the bases
loaded a strand three where halfway home
meiton works through a jam
chapman at second cosmet first kemp
represents the tying run
and he drills one deep to right field
and this ball is
caught by tucker at the wall king tuck
taketh away
brantley one for three with a single
myers takes off so does altuve that ball
smoke to center field that'll score
myers easily altoona
michael brantley a chance and a triple
he is gonna get there eight to three
game two rbi triple by uncle mike here's
julie guriel coming in at 3 16 into this
a b
that's up the middle tony kemp can't get
there yuli guriel matches michael
brantley with a two for four night
here's kyle tucker
2-0 pitch is drilled deep to left field
kyle tucker making a bid that ball's
good home run
the astros in double figures it's now
10-3
inside on three and two and chapman
walks for the second time
that's a base hit for chris davis goes
the other way
and it will allow chapman to hustle
around to third
and kemp's got another hit drives them
to right field
chapman will trot in to score davis
stops at second tony kemp is four for
five with a couple of rbi
got a chance for a four hit game tonight
oh here we go tony kemp can't get there
there's a four hit game for jose altuve
how about that battle he saw eight
strikes in that a b was down the entire
way and still ends up with a base hit
they're one out away
on the ground should do it jose altuve
has it on one big hop makes the play
ball game over astros wrap up home field
advantage in the american league
division series with a number two seed
you